[Musique]
ils y ont droit
vinci double jeu avec laurent baffie
françois rollin philippe corti carole
laure fabienne thibeault et robert
charlebois voici double jeu spécial
québec
[Musique]
mais
dames et demoiselles messieurs bienvenue
aux folies bergère dans l'art du show du
samedi soir qu'il fait beau voir lorsque
dehors il fait noir
moi je regarde double jeu spécial québec
info intox qu'est ce qu'on écoute corti
fabienne thibeault robert charlebois et
carole à double jeu spécial québec là
top albums
[Musique]
bienvenue
va commencer car amis dès lors commencé
par un mini baby en forme d'interview
parallèle bien entendu consacré entre
québec en forme d'interview parallèle
consacre au québec alors c'est toi qui
va répondre aux premiers robert qu'est
ce que les répondants premier robert
qu'est ce que c'est le québec
le québec
manière des ces communes il entouré
d'arbres le québec c'est une sorte de
deal entouré d'art intraitable derrière
les apd des anglais ou des américaines
et derrière les arbres vous avez des
anglais ou des américains fabienne
qu'est ce que le québec fabienne qu'elle
sait que c'est le québec
une place au soleil est une place où il
fait très chaud l'été et bien froid
l'hiver
elle québec sont pour mousser shawinigan
c'était lui qui pouvait shawinigan et
c'est une petite
mais en fait je regarde vers nous les
belges de mur c'est très très près de
new york
que dirais tu robert à quelqu'un qui ne
connaît pas laisser partir avec
quelqu'un qui connaît pas le québec pour
lui faire aimer pour y faire aimer plus
ferme et à cinq fans parce qu'il ya
presque pas de financer c'est très
agréable parce qu'il ya pas de français
fabienne a bien
moi je dis c'est la place sur ce qui
aura berchère le bourg carlos tabio mais
moi je dirais que c'est l'endroit où il
ya robert charlebois carole or il faut
bien thibault
le show fil vert donc c'est très très
bon c'est une un endroit on est obligé
de se réchauffer l'hiver donc c'est très
c'est très bien est ce que tu penses
qu'un jour le québec sera indépendant tu
penses qu'un jour le québec doit être
indépendant
ce n'est pas souhaitable mais sûrement
inévitable et franchement je m'en bats
les couilles mais je parle français
encore on peut se passer de ça alors
qu'anglet d'un bateau
alors qu'on l'avait presque tous
complices que oui parce que nous on
comprend presque tous en français m'ont
jamais oublié
ça n'a pas dû salle par les bons
comprendre puisque c'est vrai que c'est
un québécois qui a inventé l'expression
rouler un patin
rouler un patin c'est peut-être un
joueur de hockey
à patins à glace tant que
c'est pas québécois ça brûlait pas
toujours de toute façon il ya une belle
parce que l'épaule ça c'est vraiment six
mois par année mais il ya plein de
français qui m'arrive qui nous arrive
des fois qu'ils nous disent à telle
expression québécoise qu'on n'a jamais
entendu une autre vie je sais pas où
vous prenez vos expressions québécoises
c'est à dire mais faudrait renouveler
l'ailé où la bagarre vient pas de nom
mais c'est sûr que nous chez nous dès la
première fois qu'un garçon
alors la doite vous qui avez inventé 2d
avec la langue mais des comme un boxeur
dd com
non non c'est pas gentil c'est faux car
c'est faux katif 1 c'est faux cul oui au
lieu de fou lancé très faux katif pour
les majors comme jeudi celles où manning
s'est mal aux yeux de ses poulains
cellule maligne on sait donc ce ne
devrait changer d'air et la séance avait
largué oui mais alors va terminer ce
mini débat par par un petit documentaire
c'est bien allumer vos petits
téléviseurs et les prendre
[Musique]
marianne2 cousine française oba luc gens
disent ical ebooks kelly bout malienne
l'udc pierre marianne key de bon sens
bien très contente de vous rencontrer en
plus de vins très jeunes filles et les
qte faisait et gic gic cause et peut
bien aux crises
comme on dit chez nous dans la maison
d'un mort on l'a sur la fenêtre ouverte
c'est de l'humour de marseille au
tabernacle j'aime en voisine et pour le
souper on va pouvoir passer sur la dure
pour la collation frugal
je vais te servir des scoops ferme
intention par investigators des scoops
attendez je comprends pas c'est pas
commun l'art c'est comme chez moi par
exemple savez pas l'apéritif avant un
petit pastis note à bernac non chez nous
le fortifiant hollinger à la posteriori
parce que chez les l'invers nous allons
vers
eux
d'éviter les chaînes ça débute à lâcher
sur trop compris sauf d'ebita la chaîne
hbo fait sa pub à l'avenir
c'est une marianne vois-tu j'aimerais
bien qu'on se met quand rien qu'une fois
tous les noeuds tu vois ce qu'elle te
ferais ça serait quoi le programme bain
d'abord c'est un fil
enfin nick comme des caribous un but un
ou 2 96
on se prête les bois
10h10 les règles
on s'embrasse on boit un dernier drink
ensuite on fulmine un dancefloor très up
to b ainsi on ne peut pas j'ai compris
ensuite donc tu m'amènes restaurant tu
me payes l'apéritif vient me chercher
avec la voiture qui me téléphone pour me
demander si je suis d'accord
mais d'abord dans sa file
professeur rollin oui je vous interromps
pour vous faire une remarque je vous
fais à l'occasion de ce spécial québec
métier valable globalement pour toutes
les émissions moi je condamne fermement
le principe de ces émissions thématiques
parce que vous comprenez ce soit par
exemple vous recevez trois québécois
mais c'est beaucoup trop trois québécois
à la fois pas fatalement et bien pour le
téléspectateur il ya saturation volée
pourtant au départ on les aime bien les
québécois mais l'a avoué que trois d'un
coup c'est indigeste vous comprenez qui
rit la vie c'est la diversité la vie
sellette diversité vous vous allez dans
le sens contraire vous regrouper des
gens identique c'est comme si dans une
corbeille de fruits par exemple on avait
que des pommes match ne serait pas une
corbeille de fruits ou bien c'est comme
si dans un repas on ne mangeait que des
entrées c'est absurde les gens veulent
de la diversité tiens par exemple
thierry plutôt que de faire une émission
spéciale intello et puis la semaine
d'après un spécial grandes gueules et
puis la semaine d'après un spécial
québec ce qui fait qu'il ya saturation
la semaine d'après il ya encore
saturation la semaine d'après il ya
encore saturation il serait beaucoup
plus logique est beaucoup plus
intéressant de regrouper dans une même
émission un intello une grande gueule et
un québécois voilà comme ça on aurait de
la diversité sinon je vous préviens
thierry avec vos méthodes des missions à
thème les gens saturent et quand les
gens saturent l'audimat avant mère
dormait là dessus et pays on s'en
reparlera
mais on est quand même trois pommes
différentes scènes et on est moins de
trois contacts ces chiens honneur à la
nature des gens jettent devant le
français là
un chien on dit quand même un homme deux
femmes et femmes qui ont rien à voir une
noire une de lost
très content merci
[Musique]
avant d'interviewer carole laure je
voudrais vous reparler du coup de coeur
littéraires de double jeu le livre que
nous avons sélectionnés parmi les 250
romans de la rentrée l'amour écorché de
bernard huvelin chez grasset vous l'avez
vous l'avez lu bon mais je vous le
conseille c'est un très très bon livre
ses cochons ouais c'est assez ouais
c'est assez salée ouais c'est assez
salée puis alors à la fin il épouse il
est content il épouse la bonne femme
c'est insensé mais tu crois pas du tout
qu'il rate ses arrêts serbe sert à moi
je le recommande à tous nos
téléspectateurs et avoue ans qui le veut
tu me veux mais je sais qu on donne la
cad l'amour écorché dernière
servi en parlant du québec
c'est un petit pays où tout le monde
parle français à l'intérieur d'un grand
pays où tout le monde parle anglais et
yanis est un peu comme un accident oui
c'est tout petit cercle dans un grand
parc anglophone et puis c'est une
banlieue américaine faut pas se le
cacher géographiquement parlant c'est ça
et puis quand à 15 16 ans se regardent
dernière coup si un peu quand même
souhaité du sang indien ne s'est pas tu
sais pas non vous avez tous du sang
indien tata du sang indien vers 8 % des
québécois ont dû sabrer dans les mains
et ceux qui n'ont pas dans les vingt
noms sur les mets
ont été adoptés deux semaines après la
naissance
dans une famille mais ça c'est paquet de
souvenirs tournante cette époque c'est
une famille vraiment qu'ils sortent un
peu de romans de dostoïevski c'est une
famille très vivante avec des garçons un
peu de forme un peu voyou des filles
comme des saintes très très active mais
qui était très très très différent de
moi étaient tous assez gros des taches
de rousseur aucun
et le père adoptif je demande évidemment
d'oujda et chaque jour ils me
racontaient de nouvelles histoires donc
m'a fait faire jouer d'état drôle me
fait jouer l'état imusée vote une
princesse indienne voilà je suis ni jo
ni longues années lointaines un ou deux
jours c'était du sang des d'un parachute
des nuages n'est pas tout cas j'ai joué
que des rôles je croyais ça j'arrive à
des coachs des mais oui mais bon vous
savez chez une princesse indienne mais
tu étais très heureux oui c'est vrai
mais bien parce qu'il paraît que la
maman elle passé sa journée à chanter
était toujours de bonne humeur mais les
femmes québécoises elle avait beaucoup
beaucoup d'enfants 1 et cette femme elle
avait eu six enfants elle est à 28 ans
elle en a plus d'autres élèves mais j'ai
passé une enfance et copines on avait 14
16 ah oui d'accord pour vrai hein ça en
fait cet homme elle avait large d'être
ma grand mère donc elle m'a pris comme
septième enfant alors on cherche et
s'était formé le papa il était ouvrier
dans son ouvrier pas petit oui du peuple
et qui on vivait dans une petite ville
au bord de la rivière et puis cette
jeunesse dans la ddt fragments dans la
nature ces clichés à dire le dimanche
vous traversiez le saint maurice pour le
pique nique et de l'autre côté les actes
eux mans c'est vrai j'allais très
souvent moins les pique niques pour moi
j'essaie de faire ça avec mes enfants
mais enfin de quoi des pique niques
jean-foutre député mes enfants mais moi
j'adore et ça c'était la nappe à
carreaux rouges dans le tas dans la
forêt est allé en canot vraiment et puis
tu allais sur l'île n'y avait rien du
tout tout baigné de la mer couper les
oignons crus empêchait son poisson soi
même et on bouffe et ça c'était il ya à
l'âge de 20 ans j'étais décidée quand
même à trouver ton ton vrai père est un
vrai maire ça s'est passé comment va pas
bien mais là alors là ça c'est des
situations c'est vrai que tout ça coûte
très très rose on va pas dans le donner
dans le mélo mais c'est évident que
quelqu'un qui connaissait pas c'est vrai
pas veut savoir tout donc j'ai fait une
longue enquête très très longue enquête
et
je vais pas vous des résultats mais
c'était pas ma jolie c'est pas bientôt
plus voulu le revoir et ma mère était
morte la mère est morte à ma naissance
en cette voie là et le père bas
alors après l'été chez les soeurs n'ont
évidemment chez les ursulines et j'avais
un piano très jeune vient de placer qui
prit un coup de baguette sur les doigts
très mal parce que c'est vrai que les
religieuses a nommé terre quand même
jésus-christ d'ailleurs voir comporte
encore des croix samedi entre
700 et les seins chez les soeurs non
j'ai appris depuis a douché les
sahraouis la première semaine ont vu
qu'ils avaient pas des pianos pour tout
le monde on jouait du piano sur un banc
juste a déjà essayé de jouer une heure
et demie sur le banc mais ça sent tous
dans la même pièce ultime étape les deux
cas nous on joue à chaque être est celui
que je vais pour apprendre à lever les
doigts fins les petits manteaux et les
neuf pointé mais
ça c'est une autre pointure disons que
mes enfants pointe de votre manière
mouais mais toi t'as pas appris le piano
chez les soeurs alors moi j'ai appris
chez une demoiselle mais c'est pareil ça
a duré quelques mois comme c'était sa
technique c'était l'humiliation tour il
voudrait cela balcon maintenant sous sa
cible était un peu sous domination
religieuse et tous les gens qui nous ont
donné nos notions de bien malin ou ou
des [ __ ] ou des gens qui sont partis
avec des vins mais après vingt ans de
prêtrise doit donc dans les deux cas ils
sont très mal et ont résisté et on
allait se confesser à ces gens mais ça
éclate et du jour au lendemain un anneau
tas de l'essence dans les années
soixante dix a éclaté complètement les
églises se sont fermées complètement et
c'était presque les concerts dans les
églises moi c'est de faire venir mais la
messe en france ah oui là on parle de 75
% de la clientèle ouais ça attendez mois
et demi en fait de l'argent avec nous
pas jeux sony parce que là qu'a été pion
est ce qu est ce que c'est un passage
chez les religieuses qui a qui a décidé
de ton côté comme ça ton épanouissement
sexuel ou alors c'est c'est la
révolution des moeurs des années puis
symbian s60 beaucoup beaucoup ça donne
beaucoup d'imagination c'était évident
que tout ce qui est loin très hachée
filtré défendu quoi de mieux que quelque
chose de défunts à celles qui ont été
chez les bonnes soeurs jeunes oui
c'était plus alors là moi j'ai moi
j'avoue j'avoue que la première instance
et séduire c'était le seul homme qui
avait dans le courant septembre et oui
ça marchait pas mal c'est pas
bien
il est devenu évêque ensuite à défroquer
bidon pour toi non non mais ça peut
aider il ya un film dont tu parle pas
beaucoup dans sa filmographie qui
s'appelle sweet movie ouais pourquoi
n'en parle jamais parce que je les ai
souvent distraits plus souvent qu'on
déteste certains films mois celui là
c'est lui que je voudrais le déchirer du
jury négatif en petits morceaux c'est la
pire expérience de ma vie mon cinéma
j'ai failli arrêter de faire des bonds à
bon s'était sentie manipulée on a
complètement manipulé parce que john
buck a vu sa carrière ça fait un tabac à
cannes où il a faim il a fait un truc
épouvantable puisque je refusais de
tourner ils doublaient
résultats jeudi dans un avis par exemple
couché avec mon partenaire john gordon
dean vous marier c'était bien public et
tout il dit je crie très fort pourquoi
est-ce ça suffit on n'a pas de temps à
perdre vite ça coûte cher le cinéma
allez tu cries voix au montage lui enfin
on retombe un coma
l'un des gros mots ils montrent une
grand grand une grande croix comment vit
on est bien une grosse baisse des stocks
ben ali aussi bien au québec ces grosses
bêtes à une grosse [ __ ] peinte en doré
donc au montage moi je crie en voyant la
mythique équipe non plus qui crie pyross
19e horrible tu veux en voir un petit
bout là
elle est prêt
quand même la télévision plus proche
royal âgées sont quand même j'ai appris
qu'il tient
déjà ses métiers sont tellement laissé
reconnaît que
je voulais
déjà mûr nous sommes en colère
[Musique]
qu'est ce qu'il fait mais du chocolat
sur toi je mange
très beau très beau
c'est moi ce qu'on fait à lui à badens
pour faire
ohlala après j'ai très bien
[ __ ]
j'ai en
ça se vendrait sa des pistes cadeau d'un
chocolat
l'attachante maladie
[Musique]
e
ouais
hier est de nature assez divisionnisme
pourrait faire je suis tombé je crois
cette brèche
il a bouffé une prise de poids
non quelque chose comme ça c'est une
belle si je trouve que c'est beau ça
peut-être quelques années ça collait
alors tout le monde n'a parlé de scènes
pendant des années des alcools et
moi ton grand père était chocolatier toi
oui maman vers un pain maternelle était
une fois l'acier mais là c'était des
chocolats fou
franchement c'est tout à fait tout à
fait bien mais c'est pas choquer mais tu
as demandé la coupure de certaines
scènes non mais bien je doublais ah
ouais j'sais pas moi c'est des doublures
le film est sorti à paris avec des
coupes et envoyé 17 secondes censurer
une bonne foi seconde sensuelle oui mais
c'était des choses qui avait rajouté que
je n'avais pas fait mais avec une
habileté de montage salaires laurent
bravo pour ta culture si on reconnaît
celui qui fait pivot très régulière non
le gérant
j'entends des regards au passage d'ordre
j'embrasse bien non
c'était déjà assez exhibitionniste a à
l'époque sur sa femme le laisse axe
franc parler il faut l'exploiter j'aime
j'aime ça
c'est terrible tu as bâti
j'admets dernier dans ton dernier dans
ton dernier c'est qu'elle a créée dans
ses derniers clips d'ailleurs on
n'ignore plus rien quand on les regarde
de ta petite culotte blanche alors est
ce qu'elle est en coton ou un fil des
causes pur coton comme des petites
culottes que j'avais à l'école à son
pensionnat là vraiment c'est un truc tu
fais craquer tu le sais j'ai craqué pour
te faire
un c'est joli et très mignon tu as dit
le désire me tiens envie de dire quoi ça
ça veut dire quoi ouais ça veut dire
qu'on devient franchement génial quand
on est en étapes désir sinon pour laver
chiante et chiant se lever le matin une
drogue pour toi quoi pour moi un
excellent est bien désiré quelqu'un et
vouloir quelque chose de ta désir ça
peut être aussi un désir très fort
intellectuelle ya pas que le sexe
cependant elle est directe on a eu des
cochonnes son canapé
j'aime vouloir n'est sûr non mais une
question que je me suis toujours posé un
point à ton sujet et là je vais te l'a
posée tant pis je manage matos est ce
que tu te trompes lewis furey et tu
crois que je vais dire ça devant falla 7
caméras devant les
règles sont mauvaises il n'est pas
interdit de dire la fois dans sa vie
quels sont alors je serai chante ce
jeudi n'ont jamais trop loin si j'ai dit
oui j'ai déjà trompé le lacet dieu pour
lui alors mystère mystère jalloud est
l'installation cpv
est ce que tu te rends curé
courir dans tous les cas avec yves
montand ans a bien failli arriver quand
même hein tu tournes est donc la menace
de ce format bah oui j'ai du temps il ya
eu un baiser au clair de lune et après
il s'est passé quoi j'oserais dire
bateau c'est un mauvais souvenir non non
non pas un mauvais souvenir du sel s'est
fait piquer par une mine alors qu'ils
étaient encore bons à ce moment là ouais
bien sûr car le connaissent et simone
signoret s'était vu toi et ils partent
donc tourner la menace pourtant se jette
sur elle des dames un nom c'était
beaucoup plus beaux attendant battue va
nous raconter c'était beaucoup de jeu
tournait mon premier film français
je devrais pas dire ça mais pourquoi on
attend c'était comme eux un baiser au
clair de lune sa très jolie ont pratiqué
pour le film quoi répéter focus dis moi
tu as dit si lewis se casse avec une
autre fille je séduirait la fille
sata présen interview comment tu comment
ça se passerait qu'est ce tu ferais
j'essaie de gérer la fille je crois je
tenterai ouais tu vas jusqu'au bout
patois serait pas faim mois ci à ma
femme se casse avec un mec je jugerai
pas jusqu'au bout avec le mec s'avéra
très très copines tout et voir si oui ou
non pas oui mais on a extrait une
manière de wii je pourrais faire ça
ouais tu as dit à notre époque c'est
terrible il ya plus que des baisers ça
j'ai pas dit ça ah bon sens été mal
interprété c'est pas du tout ça je
n'aime pas juste la baisse pour la baise
pas du tout le besan non d'accord est à
bout il ya beaucoup de gens que j'admire
et je trouve ça vulgaire quelques dit ça
fait trois mois que j'ai pas baiser
série je trouve horrible bardot dans sa
théorie dans la bouche d'une femme
s'était épris tenir ici paraît que 32
pour cent des québécoises et
probablement des françaises sont
insatisfaits en amour mais je peux pas
être partout
c'est avec fierté des baiseurs ya de
vrai c'est tout cas j'adore le bon de
toute façon je pense que
la chose que je préfère le plus saint
amour c'est le baiser des matches et
tout de suite ce qui va cesser comment
ça va se passer après j'ai juste par la
bge est bon on va passer à la promo
alors
qu'est ce qu'il y a
qu'est ce qui a
fait
c'est déjà bien la peine que je mens
prennent 4 à la répète moi
elle est très bonne c'est celle ci tu
dis qu'un rôle d'abord bon on va passer
la promo on la refait
car très peu de vous deux
on va passer à la promo alors
bon d'accord ok
on refait la claque
est elle elle doit dire t'arrête pas dû
regarder les salles
moi je suis dit qu'est ce que tu as là
et elle me dit attends remets-toi
normalement qui on va enchaîner après
questa [ __ ] attrait pas me regarder
les sein d'accor m'ont fait chier
maintenant je suis tout rouge et pains
fixons pas ok on va faire une petite
interro surprise est de près les
québécois là ok alors une question de
richard maire
71000 mâcon
le remède - laure tension c'est toi qui
va répondre en premier lors d'un tournoi
de tennis stefan edberg a tué un arbitre
en servant
[Musique]
suivi
jeu non non tu vois c'est de l'intox
dépanneuse berg a tué un arbitre en
servant vraiment tu es mort est vraiment
mort de nicox intox saliver touati intox
et bien vous allez faut tous les trois
c'était de l'info
et oui le juge de ligne est mort frappé
par une balle de service il a eu
tellement peur qu'il a fait une crise
cardiaque
et monsieur richard maire de mâcon gagne
500 francs en applaudi
huron et du rhône restent à égalité 0 à
il faut pas m'emmerder mois
alors on va passer à la promo
pour de bon d'accord alors tu sais
qu'ici c'est pas une chaîne commerciale
s'est pas tf1
donc tu vas pas pouvoir vendre ton 10
comme ça pendant des heures et des
heures puisque c'est le service public
qu'est ce que tu aurais dit si tu avais
pu en parler mais moi je pense jeunes
album fabuleux production de lewis furey
producteur artistique formule est un
producteur il est super g une chanson
jimmy hendrix le reste et des textes et
lewis furey une chanson d'hervé guibert
je vais sortir bientôt 47 ou s'appelle
mirage gaucho est un écrivain aussi que
je recevais beaucoup et je pense que les
gens ont été ré lucratif salvat allez
prenez votre petit et les regards
derrière
tu mois pour ta tombe de ma consoeur
[Musique]
non
qui
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
l'iris
oh
genevois
[Applaudissements]
oui
aussi
je moi pour toit
mais il se permet cependant toujours pas
[Musique]
moi ça traîne
non
[Musique]
m
âgée de 10 ans
je ne pas tuer des fois
[Musique]
je
sur moi
aller
[Musique]
madonna t'as vu ta vu son son clip tu as
vu son livre j'ai vu des extraits de son
livre we qu'elle te fait concurrence
était dans les plans culte mais les a
beaucoup plus loin il va beaucoup plus
loin mais c'est pour moi c'est qu'elle
est très très faible part de tellement
grands photographes qui la légende
ia-ipr ça dans la vie mais non c'est de
la mise en scène ccc la belle photo pour
nous lécher extrêmement bien aussi bien
léché
c'est très très bien si lewis furey se
casser avec madonna est ce que tu es
séries de séduire madonna oui à
ce qui est dit
tu veux voir un truc voulez voir un truc
là allez prenez votre petit et les
regarder
tout ce que madonna touche se transforme
en or son dernier album érotique est un
succès commercial son dernier livre sexe
est déjà épuisée et pour son dernier
show télévisé elle a fasciné 9 millions
et demi de téléspectateurs avec sa dent
en or d'ici à ce que son assise y
viennent détrôner sa petite culotte il
n'ya pas loin car le sourire doré façon
madonna est en passe de devenir une mode
en maintenant le fais quelque chose tout
le monde je suis tout de suite allé à
l'avant garde de la mode pour capter
sera la musique d'ailleurs au début de
sa carrière quand il portait des bijoux
les quoi tout le monde faisait la même
chose plus tard elle portait des
soutiens-gorge
l'écorcé par est devenu une mode donc
aujourd'hui madone met en vente en or ça
devienne une mort des états unis et en
france envoie a servi de rang et en
france les adhérents des fans clubs de
madonna n'ont pas attendu 7 sur 7 pour
suivre la mode de la dent en or
c'est vrai que les gens trouvent ça
choquant byzance est très moche comme ça
me fait beaucoup rire bon mais quand on
regarde stéphanie de monaco il ya
quelques années quand elle s'est fait
décoller une mèche de cheveux bon tout
on a trouvé ça moche mais après quand on
regarde dans les rues tout le monde
avait les cheveux décolorés et on hurle
pas moi voilà dans north la même chose
vous verrez une chose est sûre la dent
de madonna est plus faux ce qu'on ne
l'imaginent ce n'est en fait qu'une
couverture
là donc madonna est une jaquette à ma
vie mais c'est à dire une sorte de coqs
d'or qu'elle peut au gré de sa fantaisie
se sont fait remplacer par une dent de
la couleur des siennes il va y avoir des
prix très très variables sont un peu la
difficulté du travail selon la devanture
de la patiente on va avoir une
fourchette qui va s'étaler entre 1500 et
3500 francs environ la jaquette et donc
moins cher qu'une couronne en or massif
mais tous les fans de la star n'ont pas
encore les moyens de se l'offrir
moi je devrais avoir une dent en or mais
c'est que c'est le pré qui qui pour
l'instant sa marraine
sinon pas plus tard
déjà je commence déjà un peu à
économiser et plus tard bad et j'aurai
un job
prendra un peu de linge au jeu pour
prendre appareils
de la dent en or façon madonna gagne
aussi la france
je vous le demande alors robert
ça se peut ça se peut tirer vous c'est
de l'info pour toi
oui oui parce qu'ils avaient comment les
enfin le duo la
combi sochaux vient de l'état pasqua
pandraud nom
david et jonathan une kia venga noir la
catalina langil amon d'aby voilà way oui
c'est vrai oui c'est pareil
nom apparaît dans ces deux modes mais
les gens commencent à 10 trouvé ça
marrant ça m'étonnerait pas que ce soit
d'une mode fabienne alors vous comme
dirait ma mère contraire heureuse quoi
je compterai heureuse ça veut dire
contrariante
je dirais que c'est juré que c'est de
l'intox
parce que
ça nous coûte cher ça coûte quand même
un peu de blessés par des armes à donner
à ces moments là aussi je pense que
c'est possible en toi ça va le devenir
ouais je pense que oui c'est un sujet
qui nous a été envoyé par laurence de
barrow l'est de saint cloud dans le 92
qui gagne déjà 2000 francs puisqu'on a
tourné son sujet maintenant pour savoir
si je rajoute mille francs
eh ben on va écouter la réponse c'est
que ça c'est moche ça fait un reflet des
cons n'ouvre la bouche c'est non c'est
non c'est pas bien ça je suis dit j'y
penserais pas de l'argent pour ça moi
[Rires]
non mais ho franchement vous voyez avec
ça la dorna façon madonna mercy tutelle
choisi un look je préfère ce vide du
trou
alors toi que tu as bernard et moi je
suis partie de déductions illogique
c'est que les modes reviennent ou 20 ans
ou 40 ans et que mes tantes et mes
grands parents en avaient pour vrai des
dents comme sur les couilles en or fait
son job mais
ça revient
c'est vraiment un tag and tu avais
déjouer la la supercherie et toi tu
m'avais dit quoi moi j'ai dit que ça va
devenir la loi je pense que oui donc tu
avais dit que c'est un foutoir cdc du
rétro ça ne vaudrait alors corti le
score eh bien écoutez les neurones aux
cheveux de feu mène 1 à 0 devant ses
deux compatriotes
remerciant le joueur mais tokyo
soit qu'elle est je regardais même pas
tessin mais justement
elle bodmer je vais saisir l'agent bull
alors alors toi tu descends d'un jean
charlebois qui s'était qui avait été
obligé de s'enfuir au québec au xviiie
siècle pourquoi parce que c'était un
gibier de potence non oui
oui mais non non seulement il s'est
enfui mais
c'est ses descendants ont changé leur
nom parce que j'ai vérifié dans la
région de ces macabres nous il en reste
plus dès charlebois bah oui c'est comme
des ceausescu il y en a de moins en
moins parce que lui c'était ça ou la
simple pour lui heureusement il a choisi
le canada sinon je serais pas obligé ben
ouais sur ton passeport ta nationalité
ça mon passeport juge dans l'avion mais
ma tête
oui canada canada mais on est plus sujet
britannique ah ouais ça c'est un plus de
canadiens maintenant voilà une
nationalité ça canadien moi ça a été la
mienne pendant un avis j'aimerais bien
comment dire un jour même si le pays se
transforme et qu'on devienne trois ou
quatre canada souverain je me souviens
c'était une bénédiction fait jusqu'à
l'an dernier jusqu'à temps qu'ils nous
taxe de 20% c'était une bénédiction
d'être canadien sur cette planète enfin
en ce qui concerne les rapports
qualité/prix maintenant sachant
maintenance et puis la feuille d'érable
qui est le symbole du canada c'est la
feuille d'impôts
le canada a fait le québec plutôt
devienne comme la comme la louisiane
bah écoute ça pourrait arriver sont
servis en louisiane ya plus de français
que l'on des rues non mais ça pourrait
arriver ici on un jour on devenait d'une
race ou n'y aurait que des dépôts est où
des intellectuels mais vu qu'on produit
beaucoup et c'est pour ça que moi je
suis devenu bras ça c'est pas seulement
pour soulever le monde avec ma bière lt
brasseur alain which bras ça c'est
premièrement c'est que j'écris la bière
2016 les jeux c'est de dire à mes
collègues qui sont six ils ont des
passions que ce soit des parfums des
vêtements ou des choses il faut
abandonner générer de la richesse et
créer des choses avec un produit
original un peu révolutionnaire on peut
faire tourner une machine et eon tu
penses que tu vas gagner plus de pognon
avec la bière blanche qu'avec le show
business absolument je regardais
ces bus en fait ce sont mes salut vous
c'est le chant ben oui parce que j'avais
avec un produit qui n'existe pas
quand tu dis bien on n'allait pas
blanche à l'étranger c'est-à-dire qu'au
lieu d'être transparents comme du
champagne elle est un peu translucide et
elle est naturelle
bien qui c'est un bois 2 testé sous
avance que ces 5 % d'année
plus
dire on a bien je vous dis
que j'ai dit c'est que le québec va
survivre le jour où on apprendra qu'on
est pas seulement à 6 ou la plus grande
réserve de richesse naturelle au monde
mais qui voulait transformer sur place
il avertit jean était très politique
parce que au début des années 70 il
avait fondé un parti qui s'appelait le
parti du rhinocéros c'était quoi ça
c'était un peu comme coluche ça c'était
l'ancêtre de coach mais avant leur ouïe
est imparti absurde dans cinq ans mais
ce n'était que des faux ni le slogan tg
un toaster pour tous les québécois n'ont
le slogan c'était que je promettais
devant dieu et les hommes que si j'étais
élu jallet rien fait pour le mais il est
quoi
ce qui de toute façon
générale oui mais moi j'ai annoncé la
couleur je l'aurais fait croyez-moi et
puis tu avais dit aussi dans ce parti
l'idée c'était de dire on va raser les
montagnes tout bon faisons chez les
grands lacs pour faire des parkings si
on veut ouais on faisait des manifs anti
pauvres avec des machines gones associés
sans fin la planète chose est ce
qu'aujourd'hui donc comme tu le chante
dans ton dernier album tu es devenu un
indépendant triste c'est à dire que
non parce que indépendant triste un jeu
de mot gainsbourg
dont les boxers et et sinon j'ai voulu
illustrer le parallèle qu'il ya entre
une séparation de couple ou une
séparation de pays et ça se passe
vraiment très bien et non le sourire ces
choses là et puis si on regarde aussi
bon ce qui est arrivé dans les grandes
périodes d'indépendance ou de
décolonisation ça toujours et amené
beaucoup de douleur et de souffrance
mais ça faut que les gens sachent faux
moi je suis contre les démagogues et si
on veut me vendre l'indépendance faut
qu'on me dise combien ça va coûter ouais
alors indépendant triste cet extrait de
son dernier album qui s'appelle
immensément oui
mais justement après tout c'est un peu
le problème continue à parler de moi je
m'en des circuits là le problème c'est
qu'on n'est pas sur tf1 on et services
publics alors on peut pas vraiment
pourquoi parler de mon album et si ceux
ci ont chose intéressante on va
parler d'album est ce qu'on peut parler
poésie alors à part celle qui est de
david mcneil moins vieux toutes les
autres sont de mon cousin gens alors
qu'ils s'appellent comme leur présidence
à être oui et puis un agent charlebois
mais pourquoi tu as arrêté de travail
des auteurs français parce que j'avais
envie d'écrire en charlebois celle du
québécois ni du joual mais j'ai un
cousin qui est un peu sur la même
longueur d'onde de moi mais marge mais
mes mots donc c'est pas seulement
précieux c'est moins unique c'est là et
puis
on est au début de quelque chose en
train de faire quelque chose de nouveau
nouvelle langue nouveau don ça tài tu as
rien foutu quand même manger rien foutu
mais j'ai écrit deux chansons ça n'est
pas ce que tu as dit bien pendant ce
temps là je me suis occupé de mes
enfants oui parce que le jem et les
enferment adjani a dit au palis match
léger mais
les gens enfin mécano molac ma faim
barry parce que tu as dis une chose
formidable idée ma faim
aucun nouveau la cuisse et mieux d'un
stand par des bilans me l'a dit un truc
génial vie les enfants c'est il faut
qu'il soit élevé par un papa par une
maman et par une télé bruyant mais pas
seulement par une telle exactement elle
y en a qui ont pas complices ouais enfin
c'est la maman les enfants ceux qui sont
élevés que par une télévision sont
habituellement et puis je fais pas de
tournée en france parce que c'est cher
en ce moment oui de faire une tournée en
france mais tu es riche quand même parce
que tu as quand même la moitié du québec
et les textures de la loi oui oui ça va
bien continuer je vais me payer dans
lequel ses pouvoirs un terrain
épouvantable dans le sens défraye oui
mais t'as craqué beaucoup de pognon pas
mec t'as première compagne et qui
s'appelait mouffe vous êtes claqué
beaucoup beaucoup de pognon j'ai eu
beaucoup beaucoup de plaisir mais c'est
bien et ça ça n'a pas de prix alors tu
veux te refaire là et c'est tout le
monde claqué beaucoup n'y avait pas de
crise économique bien sûr c'est tout le
monde s'est acheté un cadeau par jour la
soirée où la crise devrait obliger
d'être gros cadeau un petit cadeau tu
veux te refaire la marfin d'affaires
financièrement
c'est un point que vous êtes prêt
d'arrêt alors qu'une question de benoît
delmas qui habite 78,6 arts
la musique de la cage aux folles
elle était utilisé comme générique de la
convention républicaine juste tellement
tordu que peut-être que oui c'est là
teddy d'un abonné ça se peut oui moi
aussi son mais capable oui c'est un
succès énorme aux états unis a cage aux
folles je dis oui mais bravo vous
applaudit bravo c'est une gamme de
macbook amman
le candidat malheureux à l'investiture
républicaine n'avait jamais caché qu'il
aimait pas tellement les homosexuels
donc c'est vraiment une grosse gaffe et
monsieur benoît delmas des essarts gagne
donc 500 enfants en laponie
ça va très vite pour moi mais j'arrive à
compter que finalement la mort que
l'amour aux cheveux de feu même toujours
par deux points à 1 pour robert est un
pur 46
et qui pense pas des petits jeunes
l'acquis des bars du québec l'aller luc
de larochellière par exemple
tout ça sympa je trouve un peu trop
sérieux - peu académique ouais comme on
dit j'aimerais qu'ils fassent un tout
les jeunes en général ils sont vieux
cette année en ce sens qu'ils
sont sérieux s'il faut pas qu'ils
attendent d'avoir 40 ans pour
dépoussiérer pour donner des coups de
pieds dans le carcan de la chanson qui
est quand même trop fort baptisé tout le
monde fait un peu du top 50 je me fais
une intro de 10 secondes ensuite trop
mes toiles afin faut que ça du toit 45
mois vers moi peut-être qu'on peut me
taxi d'académique mais sa mère en temps
je fais des chansons mais quand j'avais
20 ans faisait des chansons de 8 minutes
et fu manchu et des plus longues encore
tu veux pas regarder un bout la boudeuse
un bout de larochellière prends ton
petit téléviseur à
regarder
à
ses coutumes chaque
et
m
tout le monde
les personnels oh
[Musique]
mais personne
besbes
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
magazine
[Musique]
à
tous là
eilat
ak
m
avec ce saut
à cacher du sport
j'aime beaucoup même sympathique plus
fou plus flyé bien des quelques
volailles et croyez le monde ailleurs
oui vous ayez déjanté et un très très
beau ouais ouais oui il ya du monde qui
me trouve un bon compromis entre félix
la légende et jean leloup oui il me fait
penser à moi jean noël mais ce que je
souhaite un jour cette fois quelqu'un
qui me ferait pas penser à quelque chose
que j'ai déjà fait je rêve pour mes
propres oreilles et pour mon et
vermeille met et émerveillement de voir
un jour un jour ton niveau
humilité
dit tiens je ne serai pas passée par là
c'est vrai que nous les musiciens qui
avons connu des années 70 sont à peu
près bah ouais on a arrosé tout même les
premiers synthétiseurs regardez-vous de
lula le nouy well as un petit bout du
loup allez prenez vos petits téléviseurs
sans cet effet
jean de chasse
on se place
at on
fait
quoique l'accident science
20h02
nous montrer un truc parce qu'on a quand
même fait quelque chose on a réuni 2
personnes sur scène qui ne s'était
jamais retrouvé et j'aimerais que tu le
regardes prenez votre petite élite
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je suis
as diane pépin
a propos je suis pas rendu chez sa fille
[Musique]
la violence de la souris
sans m'avertir
alors si
parti
c j'avais tellement
c'est plus
en
[Musique]
d
aussi au soleil blanc
et les portes
lassé
j'ai peur
et toujours
oui
qui
[Musique]
tu
il m
m
mais
g
o'shea
du
tiens
ses mains
il y avait même une compagnie ayant
gâché
des pigeons en dedans et qui faisait pas
là
pour la tenir
c'est absolument
sa licence
alors j
[Musique]
un petit
6 québec m on se dit est il par
l'américain mai
j'ai pu
[Musique]
cochet
je suis
dit
[Musique]
oh
oui
[Musique]
après une compagnie qui est sur une
affiche sur qui
et moi
abobo et moi
à dos de chameau
et
québec m
puis panaméricains mai
chez lui
g
tu
[Musique]
mais
et j'ai retrouvé leur sortie
elle est démolie et
avec mon
ces biscuits
alors
m
[Musique]
44 45 présenté par jean luc delarue et
le murano beau souvenir pour moi il
était venu pour l'occasion et puis avait
plein de belles chansons dans cet
hémicycle de l'émission une sublime
chanson là d'un des meilleurs que ça
fait déjà tant merde qu'on ne parle de
lindbergh encore maintenant au dessus
tout non non j'ai la chance de pouvoir
faire des chansons qu'on appelle des
stands assez bien les tubes et tout ça
mais ça se dégonfle et techland à des
chansons et j'ai une bonne attaque scott
dans la voix peut être cinq ou six qui
comme le bon vin vieillit c'est et puis
on dirait que c'est des chansons qui
prennent pas trop de l'aide avec les
adresses émouvant c'est chez moi je vais
dans mon contrat chez la team eu à
chaque fois bon ok les jambes parce que
j'avais peur tu veux que tu en parles
toujours de lindbergh et ou non dis moi
aller à l'époque où tu écrivais ça tu
prenais quoi pour pas dormir
écoute j'ai plus pas mal de choses mais
cette chanson là
quand il le pourra te lâche tout ce que
ça donne pas de talent ça continue
comme ça c'est pour les gens qui aiment
se sentir comme des génies miles davis
avait dit savoir moi mais la chanson
d'une berge contre pays d'oc et même si
c'était en pleine période psychédélique
avec les textes agen et puis c'est sa
copine sophie qui avait fait le montage
pickas et la sortie dans ton papa me
sophie de l'avion 1 et puis moi avec
louise quand même on avait
on avait travaillé longtemps dessus pour
l'harmoniser sommet parce qu'il suffit
pas de fumé un joint on va écrire une
chanson géniale heureusement séchant les
images comme des ceintures fléchées
farsi1
enfin si tout est des images qui
appartiennent un peu au folklore
québécois mais tellement avec une
musique moderne que c'était devenu
quelque chose de nous mais il n'y a pas
de mystère dans l'immeuble sis à parler
aux gens ici directement c'est que c'est
des vrais mots cette mode emo gala de
charlebois c'est ça c'est pas du joual
s'est pas dit si on veut ouais tu veux
regarder un truc là pour pas dormir
regardez troisième téléviseur et
regarder info ou intox ce 6ème la nuit
et travaille le jour
ceux là font les trois huit aux halles
de rungis pour ce conducteur la route
est décidément trop longue tous n'ont
qu'une idée en tête restent éveillés
coûte que coûte le plus longtemps
possible
jardaa dormir et je n'aime pas les vins
ça mais c'est une perte de temps et puis
en plus ça me fait peur pour certains
d'entre nous cette obsession de l'éveil
tourner au cauchemar trente mille
personnes en france souffrent
d'hypersomnie graves elles s'endorment
n'importe où n'importe quand en perdant
leur tonus afin de leur rendre la vie
agréable des chercheurs ont planché sur
la molécule anti sommeil il n'en
trouvait dans le plus grand secret de ce
laboratoire de la région parisienne
appelé modafinil le médicament sera
commercialisée l'an prochain sous haute
surveillance
malgré tout les petits comprimés font
déjà rêver et pas seulement les hyper
saugnac
c'est vrai qu'à certains moments on a
besoin gérer d'être présent un peu plus
souvent notamment type car guerre du
golfe j'irai pour augmenter nos
capacités d analyse de lecture experts
extérieurs je pense que ça peut être une
bonne chose
lorsqu'on utilise ponctuellement d'un
point de vue strictement professeurs
la pilule a été utilisé avec succès par
les militaires français pendant la
guerre du golfe elle maintient éveillé
36 heures sans effets stimulants ni
excitant
être privés de sommeil mais c'est pire
qu'être privé de dessert ces mamans une
folie ça veut dire être privé de rêve
aussi
c'est la course au stress c'est ce
qu'ils ont envie d'être encore plus
stressés allons-y galopons enfin sans
moi
[Musique]
l'arrivée de cette pilule fait du
sommeil un véritable art de vivre avec
comme il se doit des détracteurs et des
partisans je trouve ça c'est assez
génial mais peut-être très dangereux en
tout cas ça me manque ça me mettrait
encore peut-être plus d'auditeurs
anti sommeil
ouais
je vous le demande alors toi carole
c'est vrai tu penses que c'est de l'info
mais fabienne sproxy de l'intox ah bon
et toi et moi je crois que c'est de
l'info parce que on a connu son âge
quand on appelait ça des spidla ou de
même la coke c'est une façon
d'hypothéquer une pilule vendus dans le
dans les voiles en scylla d'un jeune
homme et je crois que c est vrai ouais
alors c'est un sujet qui nous a été
envoyé par patrice icare de paris qui
gagne déjà 2000 francs puisqu'on a
tourné son sujet maintenant pour savoir
si je rajoute mille francs de ma poche
on écoute la réponse utilisation de
cette molécule est relativement ancienne
pour nous qui n'y siens on utilise
depuis plusieurs années et nous n'avons
pas non plus constaté de dépendance
physique ni psychique aux médicaments
c'est une substance éveillant tu qui
sera donc au tableau un tableau a donc
il n'est pas considéré comme un
stupéfiant qu'ils se rassurent une
prescription d'un nouveau carnet à
souche mais qui pourrait être prescrite
pour trois mois à la différence des
substances stupéfiantes
intime avec l'histoire vraie info toi
moi j'avais dit que c'est bientôt toi
moi oui j'avais divers
ateliers en abuser parce que là tu perds
un petit peu la partie le score car
effectivement mon cher thierry la pilule
est amère à avaler pour ma chère
fabienne qui se fait égaliser et
rejoindre par robert et carole
et
j'accueille maintenant fabienne
thibeault à mes côtés
e
[Musique]
est ce que tu te souviens d'une émission
de télévision qui s'appelait numéro un à
michel berger ou tu chantais les uns
contre les autres mais on sait c'était
maritie et gilbert carpentier
oui oui oui oui tu vois ce que je veux
dire parce que souvient du gars qui
était à ma gauche
et à une chose comment ça s'était passé
laurent cette affaire ben alors voilà
les figurants c'était le bétail on
disait asseyez-vous à côté de la halle
aux sucres donné on y va
tu veux qu'on regarde aller allons-y
laurent baffie panneaux d'affichage
ce
on sort
dans
il
cours
les uns
c'est peu
c'est un seul
shi
et
[Musique]
m
oh
tout ça
rien
voilà mes cheveux
et bignon c'était mignon aussi n'était
pas mal non certains biens alors toi tu
avais les ou que toi tu avais le look
john lennon un peu les petits [ __ ]
enchaîné les jeux comme ça ouais et
baffie et tout c'est extraordinaire ça
document alors maintenant nous allons
regarder le bas fiche
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
à
monsieur flagrant délit
choisi non pas dans la rue monsieur ses
233 monsieur
la wii lieux publics musées le droit de
filmer chez vous dans vos toilettes chez
des amis qu'on s'entend
parce que j'avais donné mon accord
mais là c'est un lieu public un
cd 130 françois méchain non plus une
confiscation du paquet de cigarettes est
ce que vous pouvez faire
écouter
il bouge bien cher l'honneur qui m'a plu
dans la rue allez-y jurés mois sur
l'honneur
allez y messieurs wii la wii
que
alors allez y fêter ça m'entendez
j'entends rien monsieur oui je jure
à chez monsieur il faut homologué le
salon monsieur
badini alors
alors si la loi monsieur vous crachez
ben oui alors la crèche et la non non
non c'est pas ta du cash est une preuve
de plus c'est pas ta du crash et là j'ai
bien [ __ ] sur ce coup là ça fait deux
venez venez venez venez chantant rien
quoi
on dit pas je décharge de monsieur redis
je jouis dont le monsieur a fait une
petite faute de syntaxe non mais lâche
une petite prune y en a pour deux
secondes un billet pas peur pourquoi
vous parce que vous êtes mal garées mais
si on regarde les supercars et monsieur
monsieur dessin je m'en vais non rien je
vous fais un petit clown en vitesse vous
êtes mal garées monsieur sa maternelle
m'arrêter là mais alors il est alors
alors et alors non non attendez vous
n'êtes pas garer où cet homme hagard et
messieurs si vous êtes garé là et vous
êtes à l'extérieur du véhicule je vous
en ligne on est payés au rendement on
est payé est toi même c'est celui qui
dit qui y est
pardon
non empêchement bon je veux dire moi
j'ai un portable tu te démerdes ok allez
ciao crois pas j'avais une téléphonique
ya peu marqué assistante sociale jean
bat les couilles
bah ouais ça je crois pas ça mais je
veux dire je n'ai rien à péter uj h et
un taxi moi alors je vais chercher un
taxi je vous appeler pour vous dire
chercher le tout seul votre taxi qu'est
ce que c'est comment tu t'appelles ça
c'est bien beau mais la couleur
falloir changer ça oui parce que là ça
fait un peu hein
ma casquette s'il vous plaît monsieur la
casquette s'il vous plaît monsieur c'est
un trottoir non casquette ici si vous
les portez votre escale vous allez en
face s'est passé hier au journal
officiel n'ait pas lu les journaux moi
je prends une attention journal
c'est un trottoir sans casque est ici
alors vous les mettez sous le bras
d'accord à les imiter la sous le bras
voilà et vous partez au ralenti monsieur
ralenti au ralentissement
des marchés affaires
habana
stationnement
ça peut attirer dans une porte cochère
de thaler aux
9,6 et là même
le micro pour les au château ni en faire
quoi pour pour aller sur c'est quoi à
châtelet comment elle s'appelle quel âge
à la haye les bonnes
à l'époque indiqué si on y va ouais
voilà ni tiède
bon je t'emmène jungle car la voile a
tiré voilà merci
cette fuite chant classique et puis
toujours le même constat les gens sont
vraiment odieux avec les flics quoi
je crois que le professeur rôle à
thierry je voudrais préciser un petit
peu ma critique de tout à l'heure tout à
l'heure je vous ai dit que trois
québécois c'est trop je dois même vous
dire que trois invités par émission déjà
c'est trop vous comprenez ça fait trois
interviews bâclé on n'a pas le temps de
s'installer à peine on commence à faire
connaissance avec l'impact c'est l'autre
qui prend sa place et puis vous
comprenez vous allez demander de but en
blanc à quelqu'un que vous connaissez à
peine quand est-ce qu'il a baisé pour la
dernière fois c'est un petit peu
cavalier alors que si vous réfléchissez
bien sûr trois invités il y en a
toujours un qui est nettement plus
intéressante les deux autres mais il est
bien ce soir
ne pas choisir systématiquement celui
qui est le plus intéressant et faire
toutes les missions avec lui ja même
plus loin quand on en tient un qui est
vraiment intéressant pourquoi ne pas
faire toute la saison
comme ça on aura le temps de les
découvrir et vous verriez que avec le
temps quand il commencera à faire partie
de la famille eh ben ils vous le dirai
plus même quand est-ce qu'il a baisé
pour la dernière fois et robin tient les
amis un truc que j'ai à vous dire hier
j'ai baisé une [ __ ] et tout le monde
serait content alors pensez-y ceinture y
penser
merci encore
alors ta gueule bonsoir alors dis moi tu
sais que si ce n'est pas une chaîne
commerciale c'est le service public donc
j'aurais aimé de parler de ton album que
j'ai écouté que j'ai bien aimé mais on
peut pas trop en parler
enfin si tu avais pu en parler tu aurais
dit quoi ben moi je dirais chez que je
suis comme toi je t'aime beaucoup plus
haut que dit quoi j'aurais dit j'aurais
dit il ya une traduction là on est on
est vraiment fabien avait vraiment l'air
suisse parle parle calmement et français
c'est un album où je suis pas tout seul
un bon accueil avec un saxophoniste de
jazz qui s'appelle jean pierre debarbat
au départ il était saxophoniste de jazz
maintenant il est un petit peu moins
donc c'est un dialogue entre saxophone
et la voix oui voilà alors il ya onze
chansons dont deux textes en anglais
ouais mais tu travailles québec non non
j'ai toujours chez interne des textes en
anglais donc de valérie kaprisky laure
10 dont valérie kaprisky on se demandait
ce qu'elle était devenue valérie
kaprisky et on retrouve valérie kasteler
oui / non sur l'album sur ma voix de
fabienne thibeault alors donc est ce qu
est ce qu elle devient valérie kaprisky
valérie elle elle tourne jusqu'à la fin
film en italie mais je suis un petit peu
délicat pour moi de parler à sa place
c'est ton premier album depuis combien
de temps depuis 81 capes à dix on
s'agrippe aux médias fait qu'est ce que
j'ai fait lors ces québécois je vous dis
rien hein ça fait huit ans qui s'est pas
produit le temps passait super bien
parce que j'ai fait j'ai fait beaucoup
de spectacles j'ai fait
j'ai mais où est située cette intro
floch cette réflexion de isabelle adjani
dans paris match a beaucoup frappé de
gagner 24 ans a beaucoup frappé notre
ami cher c'est vrai
pourquoi pas ça pas de la bac
value de sexagénaires quand on s'appelle
charles ou non sa mère elle entretenait
sa lena qui monsieur tron est le maire
mais t'as fait quoi te lis j'ai beaucoup
tourné dans des petits lieux intimes
ckoi et les petits lieux un tgv qui
ricane
c'est jouer
ne saura pas ce qu'est la fois que je
sais c'est que le staff et qu'est-ce que
j'ai fait ma prison
j'aurais pu s'arrêter là mais griggio
non mais bon tu es gens savent qu'ils
sont vrais problèmes de poids c'est une
histoire à lviv est justement alors on
va faire une petite info intox là vous y
êtes une affaire de poids justement une
question de pierre cannes de paris
va bientôt sonner si ces critères c'est
à haineux des cures pour reprendre des
kilos en plus pour agresser mois s de
l'info ou de l'intox carole laure info
info
c'est pourquoi j'ai cure mais bien ceux
des hôtels où on va pour prendre des
livres
d'anorexie pire des gens qu'on croit
qu'est ce qu'on fait moi je le crois
autant que par exemple dans le franc
santé il ya des salons pour vous
défriser les cheveux et et ben oui je
crois que c'est des recettes pour gouy
pour gagner 5 kg par semaine j'ai vu
dans l'incendié c'est vrai vous avez
raison tous les trois on les applaudit
quelqu'un l'a dit non alors moi
personnellement je peux pas me
soupçonner de faire la pub pour cet
hôtel parce que personnellement ça
serait plutôt l'inversé
donc c'est un petit hôtel à grimaud où
on fait ce qu'on appelle c'est assez
épouvantable des safaris bouffe et on
prend cet horrible et on prend 2,3 kg
quand même en une semaine ouais alors
donc monsieur pierre cannes gagne 500
francs on l'applaudît
alors si le coeur
pour moi mais je pense que le héros et
le maroc sont à égalité 3 partout
ouais on va tirer au but ce soir alors
tu faisais quoi toi pour grossir mois
pour grossir je suis née gro cher ouais
et c'est quoi ton ennemi numéro 1 géré
le truc sur lequel tu craques même quand
tu t'es dit je fais un régime par régime
chargé mais c'est quoi ces
messieurs 1 à tous les étages les flancs
des machins et crème brûlée à la marque
les crèmes brûlées c'est bon mais pour
maigrir tu fais quoi alors bah écoute
pour maigrir s'il n'y a pas de mystère
il faut manger moins diminuer l'apport
calorique ya pas de secret et puis bon
évidemment bouger est tout sauf bons et
il faut manger moins il faut agir des
spectacles mais ouais
il a directement en parlant de spectacle
il paraît qu'en plein milieu de ton
spectacle tu t'arrêtes et timide tes
copines du métier ça fait quoi quand tu
fais ça hoballah c'est ça c'est des
faits il ya quelques années je me tais
qui gémit tej imiter france un peu mais
ça fait un petit bout de temps je vais
pas faire imiter dalida aussi tu vas
nous faire un truc la france par exemple
comment attaquer ce cas pas des français
mais si tu es que chacun se mette à
chanter et que chacun se met à peindre
des tutus tout le fonds phare est le
petit doigt et dalila tu fais tu fais
comment quand tu fais des lilas
mais c'est un peu triste parce qu'elle
est enfant on aurait voulu l'arrêter
pour le temps je les laissais par une
chanteuse pas morte roch voisine
c'était par les imitations jean ferré
jeu avoue je fais des conneries
maintenant mais c'est au tour du fait
quoi vas-y dans les spectacles que je
raconte des histoires avec fait craquer
les pieds ah bon c est ce que moi j'ai
je fais de la percussion avec mes pieds
je pourrais pas de symbole ok ok ok mais
parce que metropcs oui pas
qu'avec là j'entends
ça ça joue un sage ou un rythme ça
s'appelle la callas cologie parce qu'en
fait les gens croient que je suis cramé
mes orteils mais je fais bouger mes
orteils pour faire craquer mais cheville
j'aime essayer de faire craquer les mais
j'essaie tous les jours tu dois avoir
beaucoup plus de succès depuis que tu as
tellement main sic à ce loup comme ça
très moderne et ou non tu tires move la
tue le regrette pas dans ses fans c'est
sûr j'ai perdu du poids à 30,1 et puis
j'ai commencé c'est un bon point
qu'elle a dû attendre souvent quand elle
avait 30 ans les québécois disaient
fabienne thibeault s'aimer deux
chanteuses préférées
régine c'est un groupe alors
pas du tout une catastrophe cette
histoire de pieds qui craquent là je
trouve ça plutôt plutôt rigolo
son pied en france ont pris pas mal je
voulais voir une vraie histoire de
catastrophes chante la belle de cadix ou
si tu sais le chantait la belle de
cadix a des yeux des
sait pourtant si sa sortie
regardez une vraie histoire de
catastrophe
[Applaudissements]
non vous ne nagez pas en pleine
science-fiction si un jour vous recevez
un coup de fil de ce type vous alertant
en cas de fuite radioactive de séisme ou
de toute autre catastrophe ce sera grâce
à un système ingénieux 100% français
appelés turbo phone voilà mon invention
c'est un système de diffusion
automatique de messages préenregistrés
il se compose en deux parties ici les
messages sont stockées pour être
diffusés ensuite par la partie qui est
composé de 32 lignes téléphoniques alors
pourquoi turbofan et bien c'est à cause
de l'efficacité du téléphone et de la
puissance du turbo il suffit d'appuyer
sur un bouton pour déclencher une alerte
automatique vers 32 ligne simultané les
particuliers reçoivent le message et
reçoivent donc à l'heure
pour l'instant sur 300 établissements
qualifiés à haut risque seule la
population avoisinant la centrale du
bugey et branché car n'est pas branché
qu'il veut j'habite près de taverny
c'est la fnaut bunker où le président la
république
appuiera sur le bouton rouge le jour
d'un conflit nucléaire alors je suis
vraiment aux premières loges si j'ai
débranché au turbo von bengtsson
permettrait peut-être de nous de pouvoir
se réfugier l'attend dans un abri
atomique comme aux petits personnages là
comme le franck j'ai décidé et des
prolongements intéressant de
développement possible pour cette marque
pour que ce pour ce produit turbo phone
parce que par exemple on pourrait
imaginer qu'il puisse réveiller
l'audimat on peut penser pendant qu'il
ya des gens qui s'endorment pendant les
mises ardisson pourquoi pas et bien si
fils à ce moment là de le renvoyer grâce
au turbo phone un message téléphoné pour
leur dire réveillez vous l'émission est
formidable de cette façon on fait
grimper l'audimat dandy son
avance canon quoique c'est bien ça
n'existe pas crois pas et toi bonne
ça lui plaît quand on l'appelle gobe si
bobby
uniquement à cause quatre maps les bobs
je veux dire non c'est de l'intox c'est
de l'intox un toit c'est bien moi je
compterai redis je veux dire c'est de
l'info de l'info c'est un sujet qui nous
a été envoyé par philippe blain d'm6 de
l'est comme les biscuits bola a bola
d'annecy qui est déjà 2000 francs
puisqu'on a tourné son sujet maintenant
pour savoir s'il a
trompé un peu le dire peu le hall d un
palais replanter toutes les semaines en
20 ans si la trompe et fabienne
thibeault ça va si je rajoute mille
francs 2 ma poche on écoute la réponse
est bien c'est vraiment de la faux la
meilleure preuve la voici cette dépêche
de juillet 86 que j'ai fait alors que
j'étais stagiaire afp elle portait sur
un produit révolutionnaire loddo phoning
qui depuis est devenu turbo phone
parents que j'ai pu fonctionner lorsque
j'étais préfet à bourque dans le
département de l'ain et qui nous a
permis de faire un exercice de
simulation d'alert touchant des communes
ne savent ils pas et puis proches de la
centrale nucléaire du bugey
en service donc pour être réveiller à
n'importe quelle heure du jour et de la
nuit par le téléphone qui sonne chez
vous pour vous dire qu'il ya une une
alerte donc atomique ou une catastrophe
enfin n'importe quoi donc toi tu avais
dit que c'était de l'intox tu vas perdre
et toi tu avais dit que c'était de
l'intox tu as perdu tu toi tu avais dit
que c'était de l'info et tu as gagné en
table d'une maison
non je suis à part je tire pas dans la
poitrine
fabien tu vois gagner ce soir
l'essai du vainqueur voilà tu as bien un
petit mot
bravo
or vous avez une idée merci
c
mais toi je te gares pour la confession
[Musique]
m
et
[Musique]
dis donc robert quand j'étais petit la
confession t'as pas mal donné l'ont
quand même
oui j'ai cru à samoa mais peut-être j'y
retournerais cette année ibérique depuis
deux jours c'est des femmes donc on peut
le dire m'appelle au lieu de mon père me
plaît davantage et donc c'est pour
gagner ton paradis qui a fait une
chanson dédiée à jean paul 2 qui
s'appelle pape music
non mais c'est parce que j'avais été
bouleversée fier par le fait que le
pruneau qui était puisque je fais pas de
l'humour qui étaient rentrés par son
envie était vraiment sorti par le trou
de balle et jouer avec ça méritait
d'être immortalisés sinon ça c'est un
personnage comme on dit que je trouve
relativement sympa parce que même si l
an dernier ils répètent des bonnes
choses mais aussi tant d'amour oui mais
vous par contre hull 6 c'était moins fan
tu raconte que ta mère tu l'a mené à
rome ou à voir le pape way est qu en
fait contrairement à ce qui s'est passé
avec beaucoup de gens quand est arrivée
la balle a perdu la foi quand céline
commerce quand elle a vu que pour
seulement l'élévation et josé des photos
du pape au lieu de baisser la tête elle
a perdu la foi ma mère avait laissés
tels châtelet toute sa vie et est
pratiquante elle allait à la messe non
seulement dimanche mais quelquefois la
semaine sainte et police et c'est une
première manche en tête très mal chanté
flatté je n'ai pas tellement savoie et
deuxio sais que ma mère qui cherchait le
bon dieu n'a vu que des flashes de kodak
et que des hommes en nord elle s'est
évanouie et depuis que je n'ai amené au
vatican à rome et n'a jamais pu remettre
les pieds dans une église catholique je
sais que je fais de la peine à des gens
qui croient à quelque chose mais
demander la vérité mon pain vous l'avez
soit coloré mais jean paul ii ta mère je
crois qu'on leur ait trouvé sympathique
mais c'est en même temps un symbole
d'une espèce de paralysie quant à lui
emparé de l'univers sauf que mieux vaut
voir des gens suivent idolâtrie
quelqu'un comme jean paul 2 que dès que
des méchants que dès que son équivalent
en noir qui émettrait des ondes
négatives donc c'est quelqu'un je
discute pas pourtant de toi tu t'es pas
marié l'église tu t'es mariés dans une
chapelle kitsch à 2 min chapelle blanche
à las vegas
avec là ça se passe oui je me suis marié
à las vegas c'est un mariage valide
parce qu'on fait quand même à l'hôtel de
ville on donne notre notre est aussi
fier de tout ça et là le le pasteur m'a
demandé où voulez-vous de la musique en
boîte ou de l'agility je veux pas de
musée que ça me rappelle mon bureau mon
travail tout sonne ensuite il nous a
mariés ceinture exactement trois minutes
et demie après ça nous a donné quatre
rouleaux de 25 sous pour aller jouer au
lady luck même si on a eu droit une
pizza et puis il ya place à du champagne
stade du bébé doc / ça a été une des
grandes déceptions de mariage mais ma
femme était malade
est ce que tu es faible sexualité hors
mariage au mariage ce que tu trouves ton
ferme ou
non parce que j'ai l'avantagé d'avoir
épousé une femme coeur vous dit ce qui
est obsédé sexuel comme moi lorrain pas
de danger que ça allait me peine de mort
tout peine de mort là je trouve qu'on
devrait choisir mais quand quelques la
demande la peine de mort devrait lui
donner
parce qu'à être 25 ans derrière les
barreaux ou bien tu mens
ça devrait être les prisonniers
devraient avoir le choix
est ce que tu fais avant la légalisation
des drogues douces et oui quand même
l'égalisation du porno ça disent des
choses que moins on a enfin comme on dit
en amérique on n'a pas eu plus de ces
choses là mais plus et les galets et
moins on en parle moins on a envie
d'être dans d'en consommer parce qu'ils
excitaient formidable des années 60 avec
les drogues douces c'est que c'est
interdit c'est un petit goûter
l'évolution a su tout le monde en a
autant que tout d'abord mais en grand
principe tout ce qui est faisable abîme
les poumons et donne un cancer du poumon
donc mieux vaut boire de la bière
blanche que de fumer quoi que ce soit tu
fumes plus doit fumer un peu de nicotine
ou un bon joint de temps en temps mais
il soit très très très très bon lui
parce qu'il ya des clubs là dedans
lorsqu'on me demande si tu crois en dieu
tu dis je sais pas je me demande si si
c'est pas une réminiscence de vaud
l'éducation quand je dis mon dieu aidez
moi tu te demandes si c'est pas
finalement ton éducation qui t'a marqué
tu sais pas si tu prends du bain je suis
un stoïcien shintoïste revisionner
s'attarder de gauche mais surtout plus
lité est dans ce sens que
j'aime adoré la nature les poissons
le soleil la lune se trouve que ça
c'est ça qui me enfin qui m'inspire kim
élèves vers le haut qui m'inspire la
beauté mais mon idée de dieu c'est la
relation
l'interrelation qu'il y entre les ags de
l'infiniment petit à l'infiniment en
grand mais cette espèce de 2 ou alors je
peux pas le définir mieux que ça le
l'interrelation
interactions ses sauts dieu pour moi et
on nous dit appuie croix non je voulais
aller en enfer la semaine dernière il
paraît que ça procès au feu on peut
piller les personnes tu veux toujours
être enterré dans ton pied nous ben non
j'ai déjà un pied dans la bien
il faudra pas déconner
[Rires]
oh
[Musique]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater le in
a l'habitude abonnez vous y mettez un
peu de bleu